好 那这样 我先开始吧 谢谢大家的时间
其实今天早上前两天
有朋友问了我两个问题 在群里朋友问了我两个问题
就一个是说 我们其实在去年的时候
去年3月份的时候 我曾经讲过
我们做投资的时候 可以去做一个strategy
就是你全仓买股票 然后买put
然后为什么 现在不要去这样干
就是现在我是建议大家还是六成仓位
就不要太高的仓位
这是一个 那第二个
就说为什么做这样的事情
其实我简单先回答一下
我觉得这本质上决定了
就是说 现在的恒欢的市场
和去年恒欢市场是有本质不同的
去年的我们确实也看到有tel risk
有微波风险 有可能会暴跌
但是去年如果发生大跌的话
它调整的速度会很快
很快就调整完了
今年如果发生调整的话
调整速度会变得更加长
因为今年的不确定性会更大
就今年本质上是一个
去年欢入的焦点是经济本身
我们对经济本身的信息是很足的
从去年来说
就觉得美国经济没有衰退的风险
但是从今年来看
你对于政策的风险是把不准的
所以这tel risk的大小
就跟去年的状态是完全不一样
第二 从美国或者是说
现在资本市场来说
美国的美股
现在没有看到
像去年和前年这种大牛市
大牛市的意思就是比方说
我们之前说过
美股的erny erny增长13%
那么整体的话
erny不但是erny在增加
然后erny expectation
然后erny revision
全部都在增加
这就是23年和24年的状态
所以看得到的
就说是一个很大的牛市
就是它直接的往上走
它的sharp ratio是很高的
在这种状况下面
你放弃40%的仓位
不进去布局
这是很亏的
就是你的损失可能会很大
那么但是你怕如果
很怕调整的时候
那你可以去买个port
因为port我之前讲过
是correlation去
是关联度交易
所以当股票涨的时候
那个wall很低
也就是不同股票之间的
这个关联度就很
关联度不高
但是一旦下跌的时候
所有股票关联度都变成1
关联度很大
所以整个wall
整个wall matrix
我们叫做correlation matrix
整个wall就全部会上去
所以你的port
会白好几倍
那么拿这个钱再来补藏
这个是我们去年的测试
但是今年不一样
今年本身市场
对于不确定性的定价
就相对来说更高一点
所以你买option会更贵
第二你往上的upside
你往上涨的upside
没有那么大
所以今年的美股
就像一个
稳定上涨
但是幅度可能不会很大
但是这个中间就趋势稳定上涨
但是这中间会面临很大的波动
这种情况下
你是非常难以控制回测
但是而且这种情况下
你不太怕去丢掉40%的收益
那为什么不倾倉呢
这个是第二个问题
那么倾倉也是很贵的
就因为美国相对来说
美国经济
以欧洲 中国
Decoupling
Decoupling就脱钩
美国经济的优势还是比较大
经济的优势 科技的优势
同时的话
那个
虽然就说
为什么不把美股败掉
全部去买这些upside risk
我上周讲过
上周我讲
欧洲和中国可能会出现upside risk
中国的upside risk
可能马上发生
上周凭给脸
就马上就发生
因为当然有我们
国内的那个座谈会
主席参加的座谈会
那么有这些原因
但是upside risk
确实发生了
但是为什么不全欧印到
其他的市场
因为中国和欧洲
经济基本面和美国
还是不同的
它是在一个下情
趋势中间的
博反弹 不会很长期的
但是你要从
因为我的投资风格
更长的是
violent hold
买入持有
就是不太去买
进卖出的
去做这种波段
所以在这种状况下
你对什么样的资产配置
那么觉得更好的话
我是会觉得还是美股
所以你60的仓位
要不要挪到中国
或者是欧洲
我觉得没必要
虽然中国在这两个星期
这个星期
可能在4月前
还有一两星期
表现也看上去不错
但是进化水月
这个事情就是
我大伙讲中国的时候
着重再说吧
就在通缩经济体下
它的反弹
其实作用并不是特别大
所以这个是我
先回答这两个问题
就是说
我们这个仓位的配置
为什么
我觉得是60到65
我自己是65
付钱偏好稍微高一点
但是没有什么
特别大的差别
手上留有足够的现金
你留有现金的意思
就是你哪怕
配了100%藏文
最好配lead call
那么手上要留有现金
准备可能的
不同的政策性的变化
那么我update一下
上周的一些政策变化
上周政策变化
其实挺明显
不光是在中国
也在
不光是在美国
同时的话
中国这周
也开了座谈会
那先说美国吧
美国上周
我们说
观察到宏观
并没有那么的重要
应该是inline
这cpi
其实核心cpi
就是inline
那个10 basis point
我们认为
11个basis point
和预期差11个basis point
这个差别
几乎就可以忽略不解
很小
那么cpi
差11个basis point
你也看到
市场其实
没有特别大的反应
那么在这个之后
我们看到的是那个ppi
ppi的数据
看上去就说
结合cpi的数据
也是稍微上了
零点一
但是这两数据
结合我们
我们算一下就觉得
pce可能会
比预期相反
会低一点点
就是美联储
现在有很大的
美联储预期是说
2.8的cpi
市场的预期
觉得cpi和ppi会下降
但是美联储预期
觉得有很多的声音
觉得2.8%的pce
不一定能够降得下去
这也是美联储
上一次发言这么
就是jpeg上次发言这么强硬的
一个原因
那么在基本的行情里面
就是说我们不再考虑
terefa这些影响
那么我们会觉得
pce是比较稳定的
往2.5去走的
往下面走
甚至往2%去走的
这个趋势
相对来说
往2%走的趋势
是挺稳定的
就我们会看到
比方说
因为这里可能没有放上去
我们上周放的
就是unemployment的data
这个失业的数据
能房配弱
能房配弱数据的话
现在基本上平均值
均值在17万左右的这样
17到18万的均值在走动
然后失业率
其实下降了
call of basis point
就是0.25
其实业率下降了
大概百分之0.25
就固化出的整个市场的格局
就是我们的工资增长
相对来说
是比较缓和的
比较慢的
然后labor market比较平均
就是这个其实已经考虑
进了大概今年
70万左右的新移民
我们之前讲过
70万左右的新移民的状态
那么但是通胀
大概就是在下降
就是在稳定的下降
就是大家怕的这个通胀
是怕upside risk
怕通胀发生往上跳那么一下
但是现在看来
可能会在
接下去的联储会议
前的这些数据
或者给到联储会议的
这些数据
会告诉美联储
我通胀在正常的情况下
是在被控制
因为你看这些归因的话
这次transportation
这个就是出行交通
是有一个增加
但是出行交通是有增加
但是我们看到
比较核心的那个房租
就是那个
CPI中间的
归因中间的房租
其实相对来说
是比较稳定的
房租这个东西
也是一个
非常质厚的指标
所以去年3月份
我们曾经看到CPI在上升
但是3月份的时候
看到CPI上升是房租
因为这个东西
之后在二二年
二一年
之后在一年前
二三年
但是现在的房租
就更像的
就是美联储的数
美联储的这个利率
已经把这个房租打下来
所以它往后
有一个之后的
这么一个表现
没有看到接下去
包括移民的数量
也没有那么多
那么移民高峰的时候
曾经到过350万
350万吧
300到350万吧
那么
但是今年的话
不会超过100万
所以这个房租的数
我觉得是
不太会大规模的反弹
从通过来说
应该是一个稳定的格局
比较不确定的因素
就是包括去年
其实大部分的经济上
给到的市场的
都是正向的surprise
然后美联储
给到的市场的
一些好可惜surprise
那么
经济上的
其实我们说大局
还是相对来说
比较稳定的
所以在这个稳定的大局里面
我们看到tariff
继续是一个不确定的因素
上周的时候
我们讲到过
就是10%给中国加了税
4月份可能会Universal
再加10%
特朗普呢
最近
就今天早上吧
就是今天早上
好像发了一个推特
现在
现在美股交易很困难
因为这个要推特直播
晚上要经常看推特
要不然特朗普
发一个东西
说个什么东西
不知道
那么他说了
要加一个recipical tariff
什么叫recipical tariff
就反制性的这个关税
所有人给美国加关税
我就加反关税
但是这个反关税
其实中间是包括
这个事情本身是一个
对市场短期来说是个利好
为什么呢
因为他其实是一个
实行相对来说
会比较慢的一个过程
就我放出一个
我要反制你
其实给出的信号
是你们把关税都给加了吧
就是他是一个
谈判的开始
就这件事情
表现出特朗普的态度
并不是说
我就一刀切
也要放很大的关税上来
他更注重的是
一个谈判的过程
让别人对美国关税也变少
所以他也不想让经济
受到或者是市场受到
特别大的冲击
这是我的感受
所以 universal tariff
会不会出来
会出来的
在4月前还是会出来的
但是他着重去说
recipical tariff的话
那么recipical tariff
实施是要到4月底以前
4月底
继续有过程
所以在短期里面
对市场的定价冲击
肯定比你直接拋一个
要放一个 universal
放一个全部放关税的
要好很多
recipical的结果
大概率还是我们上次预期的
就是中国最终
不管你中国recipical tariff
反制的 tariff
因为反制不光是说
中国对美国加税
包括你中国贸易补贴
包括你中国给出口企业
更便宜的利息
给他地
这些权应该算
就是说中国的这些企业
为什么这么卷
这个话说回来
我之前忘了
有没有讲过我这个开放
中国企业为什么这么卷
因为中国出口企业
为什么在富毛利下
他有原因去做
因为富毛利能够带动银行贷款
带动了银行贷款
然后政府批的地给他
他可以去还贷款
可以去买地
可以购地
他其实从房地产上
赚了钱
所以中国现在制造业
这又回到我们大好会讲的
民营企业做谈会的问题
现在中国制造业
或者说中国整体
不是特别大的公司
中国整体的私营部门投入
为什么这么低
本质上是房地产起不来
房地产起不来
导致的就是
这些房地产公司
他要他继续干富毛利
他干不了
或者他现在有的毛利
他不能放弃
因为他要
继续去供他的房贷
他要去买地
地贷
他要去给银行去搞贷款
但是你让他
更多的投入新产品
新设备
然后开新厂
拿新地
这件事情对他们来讲
未必是一个滑得来的事情
所以真正对中国制造业
产生影响
不是美国的关税
真正对中国制造业
产生影响是中国地价
然后中国地价
已经不可能再上去了
就是这个
通缩经济下地价
这个长期反来
没有任何可能性的
永远上不去
所以中国制造业
就只有一条路
就是往下跑
然后越来越卷
卷到
一边卷的过程中往下跑
所以
但是这些东西
是会放到
特朗普的Reciprocal
就是惩罚性关税里面去的
所以最终的结果
和格局
有可能就是中国加10%
再加10%
然后
Critical的部分
就是
中间讲到
最近谈论比较多的
台积电
和台湾
就是半导体
半导体
药和汽车
这些叫Critical
就是重要的
重要的产业
还有钢合驴
那么这些重要的产业
有可能再加额外的关税
所以
现在的关税的影响
10%中国
墨西哥和加拿大
还在过程中
所以10%中国
对于
总体
Effective Tariff的影响
大概是1.5
就大概是这个量
因为中国也不是
最大的前三的
但也不是特别
那么就是
独一的贸易伙伴
所以真的加
Effective Tariff大概是1.5%
对于
CPI的影响
不会特别大
大概就是
大概这种影响
所以
对于通胀影响
加中国百分之十
不会像想象的这么大
那么最后的结果
大概率的发生的情况
中国再加百分之十
就是说
中国在原有关税情况下
今年在特朗普街内
会加20%的关税
中国是个大牛市
你懂不搞笑
就是加20%的关税
然后
对于欧洲和那些
其他地方的
关键行业加税
然后再收receptcode
就是tariff
就是那个报复性的关税
那这些关税全部加上去
可能让Effective关税增加4.5%
由中国也翻了一倍
然后其他地方再收
加个4.5%到5%
那么最后对PCE的影响
反而是
half basis point
就百分之0.5%
百分之0.4%
百分之0.5%
这个预期
我用的是高盛的计算
就是用高盛的计算
但是
这个数据
我觉得也是认可的
差不多就这个样子
因为我觉得
大概率
tariff不太会吵笨
但是在谈判的过程
既然receptcode
tariff是一个谈判
跟欧洲也要谈判
跟
跟其实北美的那两个国家
也要谈判
那么谈判的过程
就会有很多负面出来
就是有很多那些
negative news
我冲击出来
那么
加百分之0.5%
对于美联储是个什么状况
本来走向2%
现在走向2.5%
那么
百分之2.5%
是比较稳定的
那至少能維持
百分之3%以上
所以生息是不可能的
就说你再怎么样
你不可能pricing到生息
但是
降息的幅度
现在市场定价一样
两次
那么我觉得
到25年的两次
到26年的是两次
就是26年年初
25年年底大概两次
我觉得
如果是将两次的话
现在是比较费的
就是说
现在rate market
利率市场
相对来说比较费
比较公正
比那个一月份的时候
公正很多
也就是
十年期利率
在现在这个水平
4.5也是比较公正的
就是现在的
宏观市场上来说
从现在到年底
没有看到十年期
利率会上升很多
没有看到很严重的
这个
流动性的流出的情况
流动性下说
相对比较说比较稳定
所以市场的趋势
是稳定的
那么另外一个方面
就是我们找到
那个美国的那些
公司的盈利
其实这个图我上个
上个经济好像给过
这个上个经济
给过这个图
但是数据稍微有点变化
因为新的又包括
包出来
包出来一些Earning
那就是那个
我们看到EPS
Earning的话呢
大概是13%
二三年就是
大公司增加13%
科技公司增加13%
然后那个
Million size company
增加8%
那么
我们经历了整整两年
Earning
刚刚我讲的盈利在增加
盈利的预期也在增加
Earning Revision也在增加
但是今年
24年的sq
Earning Revision下降
Earning Revision是负的
所以我们可以这样说
就说也不是说
Earning Revision下降了
就一定是说
是这个市场要进入调整
但是至少市场
对于二五年
二六年的预期
没有这么高
二五年
二六年可能是更像
一个疫情前的
我们疫情的时候
经历一个很大的
depress
那个很大的压制
疫情之后
经历了很大的疯狂
然后
二五年
我觉得是一个
回归疫情前的状态
不光是公司的盈利
就是我们可能
盈利开始要
盈利会有一个
大概百分之十一左右的增加
十到十一的增加
double-digit
low double-digit这样的增加
但是你在一个
正常的经济状态下
比如像比赛中国
你这个growth
已经是很好了
但是
不会像
疫情后这样的一个
比较快速的增加
包括AI的因素
这样的一个快速增加
那么
同样的
我们看到immigration
看到移民的人数
也是类似的
那么
这个你就看revenue增加
我们其实
这两年增加非常快
就前两年会这样很快
那么
immigration的数据
也是类似的
然后这边
好像没有immigration的图
我待会讲
AI的投资吧
那么immigration
也是在
疫情前
大概每年
100万
然后
疫情后
一下子增加会很快
所以
这个都半水的
这个通胀
水的经济增长很快
包括公司盈利扩张
包括
包办
半水的就业率
变得很好
然后
这个
美联组加息
其实这一波
我觉得回归
在今年的话
如果移民的人数
现在已经降到170万
从100万
到300万
到170万
然后今年降到
70万
100万以内
预期爱70万
所以也不是说
就说一定
对GDP的影响
坏到一个什么样的程度
但是确实
相比
移民高峰的话
比前几年
会有个
30个点
40个点左右的
对于GDP的负面的冲击
所以我们会说
不是说
可能我们在2025年
在美国经济的
这个状态里面
看到的不是说
一个大牛市
23年
24年
这么好的一个大牛市
更像的是
回到疫情前
一个比较稳定
增长的一个经济状态
但是现在估值不便宜
所以整个市场
就是要
整个市场
我是认为
就是要减少投村
然后减少投村
是一个
市场还是会是比较牛市
但是减少投村
减少exposure
避免一些极端的风险
这个状态你不可持续
你不可能永远是
23年
24年这种状态
那么
还是放在美国
就我刚刚讲的
就是中国的事情
我再说
通缩经济体里面
不会有长牛的
那么
美国的3米的投资
就回到说一些
微观的事情吧
就是美国的3米的投资
半老体投资
美国的半老体投资
我觉得分几个阶段
就是最早的两个阶段
我们其实1和2
都已经过掉了
这里面很难分
是3米还是data center
就最早时候
可能是要去建数据库
然后建数据库
那么就要去买芯片
所以最早
长的是数据库公司
然后长的是芯片公司
DPC这些出来以后
现在市场的
这个方向
认为于我们
进入了phase3
phase3
意思就是我们要做
AI application
不同于比如说
比方说第四点
就是说AI
让所有的世界的
效率都提高
就好像互联网一样
我们现在互联网
让我们所有人
效率都提高
我可以在这里
跟大家开会对吧
那么
但是在20年前
不太能想象
20年前更多的是说
互联网的application
谁要去用互联网
用了互联网
能不能产生利益
不知道
AI也是一样
很多人要去尝试使用AI
所以我会有AI application
去使用这些东西
我忘了上周有没讲过
比方说now
这些公司他提供
很多AI的应用
那么这些AI应用
是调用的
包括snow也是
都是调用级的
就是我要去调用AI的
服务
然后我才能收到钱
只有mafosoft
可以说我去收一个作息
但是
我又重新画了Log
和Log函数
和蜘蛛函数
华尔街的预期是发现
这个新的东西
像红的线一样
出来的时候
应该是个Log还说增长
还增长
应该是一开始很快
然后慢慢慢慢变慢
但是实际上
真正一个使用
包括你回头看互联网
互联网泡磨什么泼面
就在这个地方
就是市场预期很高
然后互联网
本身这个用户习惯
我本来还没有习惯用
比方说互联网
在疫情之前
没有人习惯用mobile apps
大家还是跑到店里面
去买东西的
在美国
有人会搞什么送外卖
没有这种心态
所以这种状况下面
使得市场的
productivity还没上去
那么市场的真正的使用
还没有上去
但是市场预期已经上去了
那么就是互联网泡磨泡面
现在我觉得
开始炒AI application
就是市场慢慢的
把预期给打上去
也就是说
我认为这一次
可能很多应用的公司
SARS和应用的公司
都会往AI上面去靠
因为DeepSeq
让大家觉得
训练成本会变得很低
不管它怎么征流出来
你也可以去征流一个
然后让大家觉得
训练成本很低
让大家觉得
所有人都可以去尝试AI
那么Sami和Data Center
需求会不会再
继续再
因为你越来越多人使用
不管成本多低
对于基础设施的要求
一定是越来越高
这是毫无疑问的
但是AI application的预期
会上一轮非常大的预期
所以我去年开始讲
要可能会去碰软件
很应用
软件和应用的带动
就是大家尝试
先用application
最后才有效果
但是效果出来
一定是越来越慢
你公司的
公司比方说
非数
或者是CIM里面
有到一些AI的
应用的功能
能够让你更好的管理东西
你的使用习惯是慢慢培养
像Now这种公司
Snow这种公司都是一样
所以我觉得
在现在预期开始出来
然后配合4G度
4G度美国整体的
经济的宏观
都还是很不错的时候
这些公司
会有一些不错的盈利
应用层面
而且会讲很多的故事
这个预期上来之后
我觉得这是一波
如果你说短期的操作的话
那么在这个时候
是一波短期的机会
但是
出现这个机会
不能持有特别长的时间
AI的application
一定是takes time
除非你是一个更确定的赛道
比方说谁能跑出来
还不知道
比方说更确定的赛道
比方说医疗上的TEM
比方说Palantina
那个军工
确定赛道已经很过瘾过了
现在是这么一个状态
所以我对于后面的AI的状态
我是这么看
然后最后五分钟
我讲一下中国和欧洲的事情
中国有upside
upside risk
有可能我上次讲有upside risk
欧洲也有upside risk
欧洲可能upside risk
就是乌克兰停战
乌克兰停战
会对欧洲带来一波
红利的
现在有人在吵这件事情
但是毕竟没有发生
所以你说他upside一定
你进去做多
你可能会被买掉
但是upside risk
就是他可能一波
谈完之后就有些奇才
那么
中国很类似
中国这次那个大会
其实定了一个调
民营企业非常重要
和2018年如出一者
没什么区别
2018年也这么讲
所以就说
但是本质上
后面还配合了几件事情
第一个M1变正了
不管是统计上变正
还是真的变正
M1变正了
看上去变正
那么从去年9月份以来
他印钱到现在
似乎是有那么一点效果
你硬并硬了那么浅
第二个就是
我们加了10%的tariff
那么在这之前
市场预期会更加严肃
所以把固执打得很低
现在觉得加了10%
中国经济又行了
这个就这么一个状态
那么但是问题是
你觉得加了10%
我觉得最后加20%
加20%
对于中国出口企业
是更好了
还是更差了
那么第二
中国人口的问题
或者是中国债务的问题
本质上中国债务的问题
背后探的是房地产
那这个是变得更好了
还是变得更差了
其实都是变得更差
也就是说
现在所有民营企业的
这个座谈会
基地民营企业
其实让他们从共同富裕
原来去扶贫
现在让他们做企业投资
那么这个钱
会不会流出来投出来
会的
但是中国和美国
本质的区别是
household income
和household balance sheet
就是私营部门的资产负债表
美国的私营资
部门资产负债表非常健康
那个
私营部门可支配收入
在80%以上
然后中国的
私营部门可支配收入
是40%
债务成本是美国的两倍
那么你的整体的
资产负债表
而且私营部门
还有偏差的问题
就是有钱的很有钱
没钱的不债一套
所以
这个才是你本质的区别
不是你政策
你支持民营企业
重要讲话
你就能够
又行了的
你的资产负债表
没有办法修复
你还是不行
所以本质的区别是
中国的经济
控制在政府手上
那么美国的经济
是带动是
household balance sheet
就是私营部门的
私营部门的
资产负债表
这个问题
我在公开的频道
可能没有办法
太多的深入
我觉得
中国的债务人上涨
还是定位
一个upside risk
upside risk
意思就是
它会很快的涨
就是固执很快修复
然后慢慢的再继续点
很快修复
很多人问
现在是不是到头了
我维持上一个星期的看法
上星期
我觉得马上就要开始修复了
这一星期
我觉得修复
没有完全完成
可能还会修复
但是在4月份之前
是一定会停止的
这是我个人看法
如果出现一些
其他的变化
下周再谈
好吧
谢谢大家的时间
大家有些什么样的问题
我这边先结束